hello there I'm Walter Benes e AK and
this is top five it's been a while since
we've covered the best and worst
performances of an actor on this show
and there was only one man who could
resurrect this concept the Governator
himself on the loose rots Amiga Arnold
has been in the public eye since 1977 s
pumping iron a 40 year career has turned
Schwarzenegger and to perhaps the
biggest action movie star in Hollywood
history his career was put on hold in
2003 when he became the Governor of
California for two terms he since
returned to starring in films at the
current age of 70 years old his
signature accent and physique made him a
household name throughout his earlier
acting days it also helped that he
starred in several of the biggest action
franchises that have ever been released
while he's known for some bad
performances Arnold does have some very
good ones to his name but what films
showcased this Austrian powerhouse the
best it's time to get to the chapel
these are the top five best I don't
fathom their good performances number
five Julius Benedict in twins this is a
great team up for Arnold Dane DeVito had
some really strong chemistry with a big
man fraternal twins Julius and Vincent
are unaware of the others existence
they're the product of genetic
experimentation and lead completely
different lives Julius was raised in a
secluded Island and given all he needed
to live the best life possible Vincent
was sent to an orphanage and along with
his short stature is constantly getting
in trouble with the wrong kind of people
once he finds out about his long-lost
twin Julius travels to Los Angeles to
find Vincent and investigate their
parental origins this is one of several
team ups that Arnold did with director
Ivan Reitman they didn't always work but
twins is a pretty good movie and Arnold
is very solid in this his comedic chops
are actually one of his best qualities
when they're used in the right way here
Julius is a very naive guy who learns
about the world as the film goes along
he's very likeable and put in plenty of
funny situations
[Music]
nothing pavement was his enemy Arnold
and DeVito make a surprisingly wonderful
onscreen team my name is Julius and I'm
your twin brother obviously the moment I
sat down I thought I was looking into a
mirror
Arnold starts off strong in this movie
but as it goes along he's given less to
do the movie focuses more into Vito's
arc and that's fine but I would have
loved to have seen more fish out of
water Arnold
he's just so sincere there's a great
scene where he has a very nice
heart-to-heart with his twin about their
mother and when we find mama we can feel
the missing part of hers it won't be
alone anymore
it can be a famine there it's definitely
one of Arnold's best performances
because it amplifies the strengths as a
comedic actor with a good cast and fun
script no respect for logic they're
supposed to make a new movie called
triplets adding Eddie Murphy to the mix
we'll see if that ever happens
number four Wayde Vogel in Maggie this
is by far the most recent role on the
list it's Arnold like you've never seen
it after a zombie virus outbreak a girl
named Maggie is bitten and infected in
this world it's a slow turn for regular
humans to transform into flesh hungry
zombies for her remaining days she's
allowed to return home where her father
Wade thus his best to protect her from
the townspeople who want her dead or
shipped off before she fully turns and
becomes a danger to everyone around her
I have complicated feelings on this one
it really should be number one I didn't
see it before watching it for this list
but even before I saw it I thought it
was probably his best performance it
looked like a great role for him as an
older actor and make no mistake about it
he is great and you mother loved those
flowers she just loved him
and she was so strong I mean every time
she needed to fight back she did the
story has a solid set up and the acting
is all very good including Maggie
herself Abigail Breslin it's a somber
sad and at times powerful story about an
impossible situation
however there's just something missing
it's an intangible thing I just can't
put my finger up as good as Arnold is in
some of these scenes which shows him in
a whole new way the film and Arnold's
performance ultimately feel a little too
empty for me I guess I definitely
recommend it and I'm probably going
against the grain by not making it
number one but I think I'm secure and
the three performances I'm breaking
above this one in any case Arnold is
fantastic in Maggie a lot of the time
the silent moments make his performance
even better it's all in his eyes and he
really pulls it off
[Music]
Maggie is pretty good see it if you have
it number three the Terminator and
Terminator 2 Judgment Day 11 years after
the events of the original film t 2
picks up with a 10 year old John Connor
being hunted by a new assassin from the
future
the t1000 the terminator model seen in
the first movie the t800 is also sent
back but this time he's protecting John
from his attacker with John's mother
Sara joining them
the trio goes on the run from the t1000
while also trying to stop the
cataclysmic Judgment Day from happening
which would result in the machines
taking over the planet while
extinguishing most of humanity everyone
knows why this is here you know why
Arnold is great as the Terminator it's
his signature role for a reason we know
the catchphrases come with me if you
want to live
hasta la vista baby and his chemistry
with Edward Furlong as John Connor is
the heartbeat of the movie I love it
they're funny together and have some
pretty good emotional scenes well for a
robot I mean I know know why you cry
but it's something I can never do
[Music]
Schwarzenegger just Fitz's this
character there was no way I was leaving
it off the list number two detective
John Kimball in Kindergarten Cop the
quotes from this one alone make a top-5
worthy undercover police detective John
Kimble is playing the part of a
kindergarten teacher to try and find the
wife of a drug lord and murderer he's
been pursuing for years he forms an
unlikely bond with his students and even
starts to fall for a fellow teacher the
drug lord Colin crisp eventually finds
where his fleeing wife is located and
plans to take their only son back with
him I love this dude in this movie it
might be a tumor it's not a tumor I grew
up with this 1990 classic and we
watching it recently made me really
appreciate Arnold's performance he hits
all the marks here his character is once
again put in the right situation to be
funny but with the added benefit of an
underlining serious tone I suppose you
saw the bruises on Zach's legs you won't
say anything will you
please
if he does it again I press charges
everything about kindergarten cop just
works and it works so well that it's
number two on my list Arnold has an
awesome dynamic performance in this that
I think he and director Ivan Reitman
nailed
it's the perfect tone for him I think it
really holds up so give it a look no not
that one
[Music]
and the number one best Arnold
Schwarzenegger performance is the
Terminator in the Terminator it couldn't
be anything else
Arnold was born to play The Terminator
specifically in this first movie in the
year 2029 humans are all but extinct
machines rule most of the planet and try
their best to destroy what's left of
humanity a robotic assassin called a
terminator is sent back to 1984 to kill
the mother of the human resistance
leader John Connor Sarah Connor is
protected by Kyle Reese a member of the
2029 resistance together they try to
outrun the Terminator while holding on
to the futures only hope he was pretty
well known before this but this was the
movie that solidified Arnold as a star I
like this version of the Terminator more
than t2s or any other Terminator movie
in the franchise Arnold is legitimately
intimidating the fact that he has so few
lines helps his performance immensely
and I don't mean that as a slight
against his acting ability very few
people if anybody could pull this
character off like Arnold did he was the
right guy at the right time at the right
look it may seem easy but it's not
playing a convincing basically silent
killer can be very difficult when he
does speak I think that works too I'll
be back
Arnold as the Terminator works as a good
guy but he's just better as a bad guy
his most well known performance is also
his best performance over on my personal
channel this week a Jumanji 95 vs.
Jumanji 17 comparison video is up so
check that out for more content I want
to hear what you guys think what is your
favorite Arnold Schwarzenegger
performance and/or movie what do you
want me to cover next in the show leave
a comment and let me know to keep in
touch like my Facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome Walter B or follow along
on Twitter to take part in more polls
about what may be covered in the
[Applause]
[Music]
you